it's done Corey
Jenny Grace
you notice that
and we're only white Corey all right
all right Sarah
my hair is awful today
um sir where are you from originally
where'd you grow up
um Minnesota
what part
um mostly St Paul
what was your what was your family like
growing up
um
well kind of a small family
we um
let's see it was just um my mom and I
and we
um
Let's see we
um I
at school in college
and
um I don't know that's pretty much it um
I we I had my grandma around how would
you describe your childhood
very good
happy
um like
um
playing and being creative how old are
you now
uh 44. you're 44.
you ever been diagnosed with uh
mental health issues or something like
that
um no
um no I do have um
uh degenerative disc
um
into the um physical disease that
affects the neck and the spine
yeah drug use for you is that something
you get into
um not usually
um
I I just um sometimes um have alcohol
so
yeah sometimes alcohol do you think yeah
how long has that been going on
[Music]
probably around age 20.
yeah
how much do you drink now
um
um not too much I can't afford a lot
so um
uh not not too much
how do you make money
um through SSDI
um
uh that uh um for um because of the disc
disease
where you were you saying now do you do
you have a roof over your head
uh yeah
yeah I do so I I stay with a roommate um
and um I'm hoping to get
um
my own
uh apartment soon
um it's more like a room you know not a
real
big apartment or anything
[Music]
how long you been down here
um
uh
well let's see about a week yeah you're
trying to Skid Row just a week yeah and
I'm I'm actually pregnant
um
so um
the um father of the child lives here
and
we um we have uh been trying to connect
you know because um
I I want him to have well he wants the
baby uh and uh it's his boy and uh
so I and I want him to take care of the
baby
is he living on the streets no
he has a job uh yes
is your mom still alive
um I
am not sure
um as far as I I don't know I'm not sure
do you have children
um no it's a severe first
well um uh I I I did have a baby with um
Matt Damon of old people
um named Alexa
so um
um but I don't usually talk about that
um but I met him in Miami once
so he got me pregnant in Miami
and then came to Minnesota and
um kind of like this when I'm having a
baby with
um he took the baby and yeah raised her
so
but I I don't usually talk about that
because I don't I don't ever see her
and I I rarely say Matt Damon but
but yeah we do cross paths sometimes
sir where did you meet Matt Damon um
let's see
um
um Miami is where we met
um Matt Damon and I and uh it was
um there was a Popeyes and I was walking
by and it was Christmas so I just um
walk was walking by and he he came out
and he said Merry Christmas
so
um yeah
and I recognized his accent so
that led to a child
it that dude yeah
um
yeah
dear friends
um
yeah yeah
it's been interesting group of people
um you know of all faith and
you know all backgrounds
so
yeah
do you have any regrets in your life
anything you wish you'd done differently
uh
Maybe
um learn more
um
uh
you know as in um like
um like read more learn more
are there things you want to do with
your life that you never got a chance to
or just got derailed from
uh
yeah what'd you want to do
um
let's see uh
Maybe
uh
um maybe
maybe singing
I don't know
emotionally what do you what do you go
through do you get depressed you get
angry do you get anxious do you get
you go through things like that
um
no mostly I'm
uh a happy go lucky person
um uh
um
I uh I'm pretty easy going
everything is your
worried about or things you're afraid of
at this point of your life
[Music]
uh something happening though I don't
know it's hard to say it to any of my
friends
yeah have you been homeless for a while
um
no actually no yeah I wouldn't yeah
no what brought you to Los Angeles
um from Minnesota uh
uh the father of the baby
that's pretty much it and I I don't like
winters at um in Minnesota at all it
doesn't seem to be the father's Becky's
back in Minnesota yeah
it just seems to bother you know uh I
don't know me
I just I just hate the cold
and you sure there's no drug use
only with the alcohol
uh yeah I'm sure
sir what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in your 44 years
um
so take good really good care of your
friends
all right Sarah thank you so much for
sharing your story
that was you and your new baby lots of
luck
oh thank you
yeah